quand on est dans la partie l'acquis
réservé à l'équipe médicale et en
travailleurs sociaux donc les personnes
reste 15 jours maximum en fonction de
l'heure la situation de sortie possible
hébergement ou sans hébergement et donc
ça tourne beaucoup
donc aujourd'hui on est à 25 et on a des
sorties donc là vous avez l'idée de
voile à la taille du bâtiment donc à
plusieurs étages on a un sas qui est au
rez de chaussée on a essentiellement les
femmes en fait seules elles sont en
grande précarité
beaucoup de femmes seules beaucoup de
femmes migrants dont beaucoup de femmes
aussi avec des nourrissons et les bébés
qui sont nés moins d'une semaine et qui
ne
et femmes avec leurs enfants qui ne
savent pas où aller et on voit bien on
l'a on l'a observé avec elle avec 6 m
dans le profit des personnes que l'on
reçoit envoie mec l'épidémie accentue la
précarité pour notamment des femmes
seules qui
pouvait s'appuyer sur des réseaux de
solidarité ass et assez prêt qu'a
finalement dès lors qu'elles ont eu des
symptômes qui sont apparues heureusement
été entre guillemets plus ou moins mis à
la porte pour se retrouve dans une
grande dans une grande difficulté dont
qu on les héberge effectivement sur les
protocoles de durée par rapport au
statut contagieux ou pas du coc vide on
sait très bien qu'il ya des controverses
et compliqué il n'y a pas des mêmes
données selon les points de vue des
chercheurs en gros sur les photos code l
agence régionale de santé
on est autour de 15 jours d'un point de
vue médical avec nécessité de suivre à
plus de près de 8 10 jours s'assurer que
depuis le début des symptômes
jusqu'au but dix jours il n'est pas eu
d'aggravation à partir de ce moment à la
regarder si pendant deux trois jours il
n'y a pas de signe particulier notamment
de la fièvre des courbatures ou autres
et à partir de là on va étudier avec
l'équipe d'europe
l'aspect social savoir s'ils peuvent
retourner leur lieu d'hébergement ou pas
s'il ya dans le groupe à et donc on a on
a du temps si on a du temps pour pouvoir
bien sûr d'un point de vue médical et
s'assurer de mieux au niveau social
personne ne retourne à la rue c'est une
exigence conseil fixe et est donc on
prend le temps nécessaire pour s'assurer
de la continuité de la prise en charge
médicale et sociale il ya des équipes de
puéricultrices et et de sa femme qui
viennent régulièrement aussi sont des
partenaires l'intervention poursuivre
des femmes enceintes notamment et les
nourrissons on a une équipe de
psychiatres avec le docteur merkel qui
est aussi assez spécialiste des
questions de psychiatrie de rue d'une
précarité et puis on peut s'appuyer sur
un centre de santé de proximité pour
tout ce qui relève des labos et est pour
les pcr et on peut s'appuyer aussi sur
le sens de santé sexuelle de la ville de
paris on a des femmes qui ont été
violées pendant la migration qui ont des
grossesses découverte
avec parfois des statut sérologique vih
wordpress pire on vit plus des violences
terribles elles ont besoin d'être
accompagnés sur cette prise en charge
médicale voire psychologiques
ça fait partie aussi du package de prise
en charge globale on s'intéresse aux
patients et aux patients dans leur
globalité
que ce soit d'un point de vue médical et
d'un point de vue social